our correspondent Tom Palmetto joins me
now from County Donegal evening Tom a
close-knit community left reeling
yes an explosion that was over in a
matter of seconds that has left a
lifetime of sorrow in this place and as
we know all of the vit10 victims come
from this area this remote beautiful
part of County Donegal and tonight a
tribute to one of them issued by
Letterkenny Rugby Club in the nearest
Big Town and this is to one of their
players Leona Harper they say we are
heartbroken to say our worst fears have
been confirmed Leona Harper tragically
lost her life yesterday in Cruise lock
Leona was a talented rugby player and an
important part of our under 14 girls
team
see Leona's parents Hugh and Donna her
brothers Anthony and Jamie and all of
her teammates we offer you our deepest
condolences and support
there are no words that feel strong
enough at a moment of deep Sorrows such
as this rest in peace Leona and that
sentiment I'm sure will be repeated
again and again in the coming hours and
days as we learn more about the 10
people who lost their lives here and one
of the Striking things I think from
today was just how the Emergency
Services hailed the work of locals here
in the immediate moments after the
explosion how they just rushed to try
and help in any way they could in the
words of the emergency services to try
and help their people their Village
their community and as they searched for
survivors together they will support and
each other and grieve together but as
that process starts to get underway and
that no doubt will be many many
difficult days ahead they will know that
this remote place will never quite be
the same again as it was before this
cruel explosion